Good morning wife
Because
This is gray look out your window why you know?
I'm taking you away for the weekend. I just can't believe this is my life, then I get to live with you
That meant nothing to me before you
Anna Gray's office we wanted to welcome the new fiction editor
I bought it for us. I should have asked you first oh
My god
Christian
This is Jim Matteo the architect this location is perfect. I'm going to build you a fabulous house
Please stop speaking of my husband as if I weren't here, and you may call me mrs. Gray
I'll pick you up the fire. I may not be done by then
Career follows
How the hell are you Anna Jack what do you want?
So you want to play yes, sir
I made a vow to love you faithfully
Forsaking all others. Did you sleep with her?
To comfort you when times of need and to keep you safe
First long as we both shall live
Tirzah boy